on va prendre tout de suite la direction
de l'assemblée nationale au menu
l'examen d'un projet de loi sur la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire dès
le 10 juillet le texte prévoit une
période transitoire durant laquelle des
restrictions resteront possibles elle
seule la guyane et mayotte resteront
sous le coup de l'état d'urgence
initiale jusqu'au 30 octobre
dans l'opposition on s'alarme on va voir
pourquoi avec notre reporter les la
fameuse ou à l'assemblée nationale elle
est la femme ouzou alors cette mesure
d'exception elle suscite l'inquiétude
dans les rangs de l'opposition
oui effectivement ça montables plusieurs
points d'inquiétude a dans ce projet au
sein de l'opposition puisque cette
période de transitoire que le
gouvernement voudrait voir prolonger
jusqu'au 30 octobre permettrait
d'interdire certains rassemblements
permettrait aussi de restreindre la
circulation des personnes ou encore
l'accueil du public dans certains
établissements alors plusieurs députés
de l'opposition notamment voit dans ce
projet finalement un état d'urgence qui
ne dit pas son nom rappelez-vous ce
régime dérogatoire au droit commun qui
est entrée en vigueur lors de l'épidémie
ducobu 19 donne et d'énormes moyens au
gouvernement des moyens exceptionnels et
permet de limiter plusieurs libertés
publiques alors du côté du gouvernement
on explique qu'une sortie sèche de
l'état d'urgence serait dangereuse en
cas de résurgence du virus mais pour
beaucoup de députés ici il ya d'autres
moyens d'éviter une vague une nouvelle
vague de l'épidémie du corona virus à
l'instar de philippe gosselin député l
ère de la manche à qui nous avons
entendu nos micros je propose de
l'écouter on a un texte de loi qui nous
dit que c'est la fin de l'état d'urgence
très bien mais qui en fait par
différentes mesures la prolonge cette
période avec des interdictions ou des
réglementations d'aller et de venir
du droit de manifester des éléments
quand même important tout ça nous paraît
vraiment à contre-courant nous paraît
dangereux liberticide et ça ne nous va
pas évidemment nous avons d'autres
moyens juridiques nous avons le code de
la santé publique qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de répondre à un certain
nombre de questions on a le droit commun
le droit habituel qui permet au préfet
de réglementer le droit de manifester
qui permet d'avoir des déclarations de
manifestations etc
donc je crois que le droit commun en
réalité permet d'assurer un certain
nombre de difficultés potentielles on a
de nombreux états en europe qui n'ont
absolument pas eu recours à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire avec qui est un
régime d'exception à lorsque philippe
gosselin nous a confié aussi c'est que
finalement ils voyaient dans ce projet
du gouvernement finalement une tentative
peut-être de faire oublier une gestion
très critiquée de cette crise du
coronavirus alors que une commission
denquête commencé ce lundi sur la
gestion des masques des stocks de
masques notamment et c'est vrai que ce
point de vue revient régulièrement ici
dans cette salle des quatre colonnes
l'impression que le gouvernement
finalement veut faire oublier beaucoup
de problèmes pendant cette crise du
coronavirus alors les débats se
poursuivent à bâtons rompus et ce qui
revient régulièrement au sein de
l'hémicycle c'est que le gouvernement
doit prévoir
effectivement mais qu'il ne faut pas
faire d' abus de pouvoir merci beaucoup
à vous de la fameuse ou pour toute cette
précision